WITH THAT I WILL TAKE QUESTIONS.
>> I WANT TO ASK ABOUT THE
WOODARD INTERVIEWS.
DID PRESIDENT TRUMP MISLEAD THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT THE THROAT
OF COVID, A PANDEMIC THAT COST
THE LIVES OF 200,000 AMERICANS?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THIS PRESIDENT WHEN YOU ARE
FINDING INSURMOUNTABLE
CHALLENGES IT’S IMPORTANT TO
EXPRESS CONFIDENCE AND EXPRESS
CALM.
>> IS PLAYING IT DOWN EXPRESSING
CALM?
>> CAN YOU READ THE REST OF THE
QUOTE.
>> THAT’S HOW MUCH THEY PUT IN
THERE.
>> YOU EXCLUDED THE LAST PART.
I DENY.
HE DOESN’T WANT TO SEE CHAOS
WHEN YOU FAILED TO READ.
THE PRESIDENT JUST DAYS AFTER
HAVING THIS DISCUSSION WITH BOB
WOODARD SAID THIS.
FROM THIS PODIUM.
MARCH 30th I WANT THEM TO STAY
CALM.
WE ARE DOING A GREAT JOB.
STAY CALM.
IT WILL GO AWAY BUT IT’S
IMPORTANT TO STAY CALM.
THIS PRESIDENT DOES WHAT LEADERS
DO.
STAY CALM AND RESOLUTE AT A TIME
WHEN YOU FACE A CHALLENGE.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> THE PRESIDENT LIED TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC ABOUT THE THREAT
POSED BY COVID?
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS NEVER LIED
TO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC ON COVID.
HE WAS EXPRESSING CALM AND HIS
ACTIONS REFLECT.
THIS JANUARY 6th THE CDC ISSUED
A WUHAN TRAVEL NOTICE.
I REFER YOU TO DR. FAUCI WHO
SAID THIS PRESIDENT HAD AN
IMPRESSIVE RESPONSE.